[Musique]
elle a chanté sur toutes les grandes
scènes du monde
[Musique]
et dans les soirées les plus
prestigieuses
[Musique]
aux cérémonie des Jeux olympiques de la
Coupe du monde de soccer du prix Nobel
de la Paix l'africaine a même chanté la
Marseillaise sur les Champs-Élysées
[Musique]
je chante parce que je crois
profondément que les êtres humains que
nous sommes nous sommes capables de
merveilles de faire de superbes choses
et que par manque de courage et de peur
on a plutôt tendance à aller vers la
violence le chaos
[Applaudissements]
l'artiste est avant tout béninoise elle
a eu la piqûre de la scène très jeune au
théâtre que tenait sa mère à côté nous
c'est à cause de moi qui est devenu
chanteuse parce que je faisais du
théâtre aussi et puis à partir de 5 ans
elle a commencé à chanter madame qui
joue est aujourd'hui décédé mais les
valeurs qu'elle a transmises en héritage
à sa fille son bien vivantes
on arrive
angélique est ambassadrice de bonne
volonté de l'UNICEF depuis 20 ans en
décembre elle était en mission au nord
du Bénin où commence à affluer des
réfugiés du Niger et du Burkina Faso qui
fuit les attaques de groupe djihadistes
elles craint pour les jeunes sans emploi
cette violence cette colère en eux c'est
ce sentiment d'humiliation de nos servir
à rien de ne pas avoir de métiers de
passer la journée à se dire mais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire il y a rien
qu'on puisse faire car pour ces millions
de jeunes des pays du Sahel le choix est
impossible prendre les armes ou une
pirogue vers l'Europe qui ne veut pas de
c'est une hypocrisie parce que une fois
que les gens sont dans le pays on les
exploitent et ceux qui ramassent les
poubelles et qui s'occupent des
personnes âgées dans les pays riches
sont des immigrés qui viennent d'Afrique
[Musique]
de vouloir de penser qu'à profiter des
ressources de l'Afrique en
humiliant et en oubliant les droits des
humains qui habitent en Afrique il y
aura jamais la paix son artiste africain
la misère est une bombe à retardement
qui menace tout le monde les pays rétent
pourquoi aujourd'hui nos démocraties
sont si fragilisées c'est parce que dans
nos politiques dans nos pays il y a un
système qui privilégie une minorité par
rapport à une majorité qui souffre et
qui a souffert en silence et qui ne veut
plus souffrir en silence
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la béninoise rejoint au
palmarès du prix polar les rangs des
Myriam Makeba Paul McCartney Peter
gebrouillard Pink Floyd Dizzy Gillespie
bibi King et d'autres géants de la
musique et moi toute ma carrière tout ce
que j'ai fait c'est essayer de créer des
points de culture pour qu'on puisse
avoir des discussions quand ça c'est
qu'on discute et quand on regarde la
planète la planète Terre depuis l'espace
il y a pas de frontière si nous avons
créé les frontières nous pouvons les
défaire